good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
please allow me to welcome you to this
edition of our 2020 2021
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series
this lecture is supported by uva's
integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain
institute
the college of arts and sciences the
school of data science and through a
grant from the national institutes of
general medical sciences
it is my honor and privilege today to
welcome our speaker
dr marianne martone from the fair data
informatics lab
at the university of california san
diego
dr martone received her bachelor of arts
from wellesley college in biological
psychology and ancient greek
and her phd in neuroscience from the
university of california san diego
she is a professor emeritus at us ucsd
but maintains an active laboratory and
currently serves as chair of the
university of california academic senate
committee
on academic computing and communications
she began her career as a neuroanatomist
specializing in light in electron micro
microscopy
but her main research for the past two
decades has been focused on the
informatics
associated with neuroscience she's led
the neuroscience informatic excuse me
the neuroscience information framework
the nif
a national project to establish a
uniform resource uh description
framework for neuroscience
and the niddk information network or the
dknet
a portal for connecting researchers in
digestive kidney and metabolic diseases
to data tools and materials
she served for five years as the
editor-in-chief of brain and behavior
and open access journal
and has just launched a new journal as
editor-in-chief called
neuro commons dr martone is the past
president of the force
11 task force an organization dedicated
to advancing scholarly communication
and e scholarship she's completed a
two-year
uh stint as the chair of the on the
council of training science
and infrastructure for the international
neuro informatics coordinating facility
based in stockholm sweden
and serves as the chair of their
governing board since
quote-unquote retiring as an emerita
professor
at ucsd she has served as the director
of biological sciences for
hypothesis a technology nonprofit um
developing an open annotation layer for
the web
and founded cycrunch a technology
startup based on technologies developed
through the nif and the dknet projects
dr martone's lecture today is entitled
the use of ontologies for fair
neuroscience and as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for
recording via youtube if you are
watching via youtube
thank you so much for joining us also
our specially selected 2021
uh biomedical data science innovation
lab participants
are encouraged to submit any questions
for dr martone by the chat feature in
their zoom sessions i will synthesize
the questions
and i will ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of the
lecture
and with that welcome marianne thank you
so much we are really looking forward to
your lecture
oh thank you so much jack for inviting
me and i'm really looking forward to
presenting to you
on this topic that has occupied me for
as you'll see many many years
i just wanted to wave to you live but
then i'm going to turn off my video so
you don't have to be distracted by my
little moving face
uh and let me start my timer to make
sure that i don't go
over so let's see
oops i'm in the wrong place
there we go okay so this is not a typo
at the top of the slide i didn't forget
to put something in
but i always start or any lecture that
you hear
on neuroscience and the data and
informatics challenges of neuroscience
always starts with some version of this
slide and that's why i put it here
it basically means they will show you
all the different scales
over which neuroscience needs to be
understood
from the level of the behaving animal
down to
the subcellular and molecular level over
here let me minimize this
individual molecules it talks about the
different modalities of data
that we need to acquire from light and
electron microscopy
to physiology traces to behavioral data
so we know that neuroscience data is
complex
and it therefore presents unique
challenges when trying to develop
data sharing platforms data sharing
strategies and
uh fair data approaches to neuroscience
so just to summarize it's a diverse
experimental domain
with very complex experimental paradigms
has to
traverse multiple temporal and spatial
scales there is no dominant model system
people work on all sorts of organisms
all over the place
very heavily reliant on spatial
information so imaging brain atlas is
common coordinate systems
and technology and the
the new technology is constantly being
developed and the impact of this
technology can be transformative in the
understanding of structure and function
of the brain so what we know about the
brain is
very much dependent on the techniques
that we use to probe it
and when i was in graduate school one of
my professors introduced this
phrase of disputed origin the gain in
brain lies mainly in the stain
and what that meant was that if you look
at great leaps in neuroscience
such as cahal's neuron theory it was
really due
to different ways of probing the nervous
system and being able to
visualize them so for our topic today
which is ontology
uh the result of the nature of
neuroscience the history of neuroscience
and the heavy technological flux is that
there's an extraordinarily large number
of vocabularies that people use to
describe
this organ so
clearly neuroscience needs to be fair
right if one is going to
be able to acquire this data using these
different techniques across the globe
no one laboratory or no one group or no
one country
is uniquely able to acquire all the data
that they need
you need to be able to somehow put this
data together
and if you want to put this together
data together of course you have to be
able to find it
you've got to be able to access it you
need to be able to reuse it
and we'd like at some level if we're
going to traverse these scales to make
sure that this data is at least some
level
interoperable that is i can take results
that come from lab 1
results from lab 2 and put them together
in some way doesn't mean that they're
consistent and that will be a constant
theme of my talk it just means that i at
least have a shot at being able to take
this data
put it together and look to see if i can
build an integrated
picture of the way that the brain works
so i'm not going to focus
on the far parts of fair i'm going to
focus exclusively here on the
interoperability part
and if we look at that in more detail we
see that it asks for several things it
asks for metadata and data to use a
formal accessible shared
and broadly applicable language for
knowledge representation
those who know the people who are behind
fair
assume that they're talking about
something like rdf the resource
description
framework but in fact they constantly
say that that is not true that
it is agnostic but it shouldn't be
custom and it shouldn't be proprietary
it should be something that is
is available to everyone and that can
translate some of these things
into a knowledge representation it
should use vocabularies that themselves
follow the fair principles and we'll
talk about what that means in just a
moment
and it should also include qualified
references explicit references
meaningful references to other data
so this idea of being able to link
across things means that if i have two
pieces of information
in two different places what is the
relationship between those
and that should be ideally in a machine
computable form
so what is a fair vocabulary well
essentially
it has the characteristics of fair data
and fair data
if i'm sure you're familiar with the
principles have these persistent
identifiers which uniquely
identify a particular thing that unique
identifier ties
metadata about that thing whether it's a
data file whether it's an article
to that persistent identifier it has
relationships to other things
as we just talked about and in the realm
of computer science and data science
really
uh these things are characteristic of
those structures that we call ontologies
and
also controlled vocabularies in its
broadest sense
ontologies are representations of human
knowledge
that are machine computable at least
that's how we use it in data science and
over here you see
an example from a community ontology
called uberon which is anatomical
ontology
there's a preferred name it's got an
identifier a full uri
it's got relationships to other things
it's got mappings to other identifier
systems
and this would be what we would consider
a fair ontology
a fair vocabulary because it is
represented in
owl ii which is a a common interchange
language for ontologies that let
some sort of reasoning and other
operations be performed on this
vocabulary
so just again by way of introduction
what is an ontology
i sort of introduced it already i assume
many are familiar with this
but in its formal definition an ontology
is an explicit formal representation of
concepts
relationships among them within a
particular domain
that express human knowledge in a
machine-readable form
in philosophy however an ontology is a
theory of what is
and one of the themes of this talk is
that clashing definitions between
philosophy of a theory what is with an
experimental science like neuroscience
which is we don't know what is we're
still trying to find out
is one of the reasons that it's been
somewhat difficult to actually build
ontologies for neuroscience but you can
see a simple one over here on the right
brain has a part called a cerebellum it
has a
purkinje cell layer which has a part
called a purkinje cell which is a type
neuron so basically you have these
relationships these concepts and the
relationships between them
and we'd like to say that ontologies as
i'll show in a minute
are uniquely crucial to neuroscience
because if you look at the data types
that are associated with neurons and
molecules and the data types that are
associated
perhaps with brain the only thing that
really relates them together
in many cases because you can't always
resolve individual neurons in the brain
are these conceptual networks that is no
single data type has
all of this complexity in it at any
given time so that i think their unique
neuroscience is uniquely reliant on them
as i'll show you in just a moment
so a lot of my introduction to
ontologies
came through a project called the
neuroscience information framework which
jack mentioned in the introduction
this project's been going on for a long
time it's actually before 2008
i know that you're young faculty so many
of you were probably very young when we
started this
and it was an initiative of something
called the nih blueprint
consortium these are all the institutes
that are involved in neuroscience
who actually had been funding a lot of
different resources to produce databases
and online tools and materials and
services
and this predated nih reporter predated
a lot of things that are now available
for us to find these things
but basically it was very difficult to
know
what resources were out there and
available to the neuroscience community
so
nif at its heart was a cataloging
exercise and we maintain a very large
catalog of these resources to find out
what is being built out there what
domains do they cover what don't they
cover
and it also was an explicit charge for
how can we make them better in the
future
that is how can we find these and how
can we make them better in the future
so that essentially again they are fair
so this is just a slide a screen share
screenshot of the current interface of
the nif that still exists and still goes
on
one thing i do want to just mention is
that the technology platform it has
is built on has been rebranded cycrunch
and so if throughout this talk you hear
references to cycrunch that's what i'm
talking about it's basically the
technology stack but it was one of the
first attempts to really federate
in quotes across independently developed
maintained
databases and data sources so it turned
out when we did our catalog that there
were hundreds to thousands
of these databases out there broadly
defined in neuroscience but a lot of
them just general biomedicine because
everything biomedical is pretty much
relevant to each other
and nif initially was performed in the
very much pre-fair
uh state so there were no standards
there were no desire to develop any
standards
and there was certainly no desire to
federate so nif essentially created an
index across
data sets as they were not as we would
desire them to be
and of course you can imagine that it
was quite difficult
there's an old saying the problem is as
i've seen this old saying across
multiple domains
that researchers in bioinformatics would
rather use somebody else's toothbrush
than somebody else's code
i've seen the same thing in molecular
biology with gene names and i've seen
the same thing in anatomy in terms of
anatomical names
and that meant when you were actually
going to try to search across these
things
every variant of a name that you could
possibly think of was there
and every possible synonym for a name
was there
so there was very little underlying
similarity between
different data sources and how bad was
this i did a little analysis
nif at the time had seven databases that
contained connectivity
information about either primary data or
claims from the literature that brain
structure a
was connected to brain structure b and
if we looked across these seven sources
there were eighteen hundred
unique brain terms this doesn't include
uh bird brain
terms and if you try to compare them
that you saw that the number of times
that the exact same term
to describe a brain structure was
present in
more than one database was 42. so 42 out
of the 1800 unique brain terms
had the same exact usage across those if
you added synonyms
there were 99 of them so some of them
was just synonymous
but if you added the first order part
tony matches you got up to about 400.
so what you saw was that people do not
use a common terminology to describe the
same brain structure
but a lot of times they weren't
describing the entire brain structure
they were
describing parts of that brain structure
and that that's what those relationships
were
so we realized that in order to search
sniff effectively
we needed some sort of ontology to sit
behind it that would help us navigate
these synonyms it would help us navigate
these relationships in order to provide
more effective search
and we created something called the nif
standard ontology back in 2008 it still
exists and is available
in bioportal and through nif and it was
essentially a collection of community
ontologies these were ontologies that
existed out in the community uber on
we've referenced already
gene ontology you may be familiar with
that covered the major anatomical
domains
now in many cases they didn't cover
neuroscience particularly well
and but they were a good starting point
to say okay here's a list of brain
regions here's a list of cell types
okay and nif did a lot of work to try to
improve
the neuroscience coverage in a lot of
these as well so
this was used in a bat as a back end to
the search enif so that if you search
nif for something like they called the
interior cingulate
area it would expand into a synonym
remember there was no mapping
the people who created this were very
reluctant or
unwilling to put identifiers into their
system so it was generally free text
and we had to disambiguate a lot of
things but essentially
if you put this in you would get back
all the data that referenced one or more
of these terms now this wasn't perfect
it was prone to
a lot of false positives cga for example
is gene
but it did at least let us query broadly
across hundreds of information sources
to see what they had
about the anterior cingulate but you
might say
and this was a major concern to the
neuroscientists just because they said
this was from the anterior cingulate
cortex
were they really meaning the same thing
and the answer was almost assuredly not
which i'm going to
show you in a moment but what we try to
convince the neuroscientists is like
look we're not trying to get to the
definitions here we're just trying
to say that if you are claiming that you
have something about the anterior
cingulate cortex if you're claiming that
you have some data on this
or some knowledge about this we would
like to know about it so we're really
not concerned
uh whether or not the usage of the term
anterior cingulate cortex
was consistent across these rather we
were trying to track
assertions about the anterior cingular
cortex
but as i mentioned before neuroscience
has a lot of vocabularies
and part of a lot large reason why we
have a lot of those vocabularies
is because the way that you break up
something called the anterior cingulate
cortex or even where it is
is not in great agreement amongst
different groups so this is one of my
favorite slides to just illustrate one
of the problems
this is a study that is on the
prefrontal cortex of the mouse this is
just the mouse
nothing else it's just one chunk of
cortex right in the beginning
right in front of the anterior cingulate
in fact
there are six different parsilation
schemes
that have been superimposed on this
particular piece of tissue
based on one single technique six
different ones
and if you bother to align them together
you see that they don't really align
they don't use the same vocabulary
the lines don't cross in the same place
and so the relationships between what
one person says is anterior cingulate
and what its subparts are and what
another says is anterior cingulate
is very dependent on technique it's
dependent on a whole bunch of different
factors
but it is not an exaggeration to say
that these don't agree and this is not
people
being obstinate it's that in fact we
don't know
everyone who proposed one of these
particulation schemes had evidence that
this in fact was
a an accurate representation of how you
should divide
up this area of cortex and how you
should define its boundaries
but they don't necessarily agree
so it turns out that in neuroscience
that's true for a lot of our
knowledge what you would consider
fundamental knowledge so you might think
that by now since we the concept that
neurons
are the cell types of the nervous system
has been around for 100
some odd years that we would understand
how many neuron types are in the brain
but in fact this was an announcement of
the nih or the u.s brain initiative back
in 2014
uh and one of the things they said was
the mammalian brain contact
contains a vast number of cells they're
generally grouped by broad classes
but it is currently unknown exactly how
many classes exist
so in fact when people disagree about
what cell types comprise a region
again they're not being just obstinate
it's that we honestly don't know
so if you're going to take knowledge
about a domain and formalize it it would
help that you understood what knowledge
you were actually formalizing
and what we learned over the years when
we were trying to use
uh common procedures that were in place
for building very successful ontologies
like the gene ontology
was that they really didn't work because
that sort of
what they normally do is they would get
a bunch of experts in the room and
everybody would agree
that these were the brain regions and
this is how they were organized
and no amount of sitting in a room
trying to gain consensus on a cell type
or brain region is going to work we've
tried we've tried for many years and
that's because again it's simply not
known
it's not that there is not shared
knowledge
so the fact if you look at the
neuroscience literature you will see
things like pyramidal cell and you'll
see things like anterior cingulate
cortex
it just doesn't go very deep so we have
a shared
conceptualization of neuroscience we can
talk to each other we can teach
neuroscience to each other
but if you then try to go into the
particulars you find
that these more granular concepts which
are really critical for annotating
experimental data are almost completely
reliant on specific experimental
techniques
and even then as in the case of the
nissel they may not be adequate to get
to anything that we may consider ground
truth there may not be a ground truth i
think we have to also you know
kind of uh a grapple with that so
it when nif was going ahead and trying
to build these ontologies we really
uh we we started to understand that the
typical way of doing this was not going
to work and something that was much more
flexible
and respected the fact that on that
neuroscience was really an experimental
domain we were on the cutting edge of
trying to figure out how this tissue was
organized
was needed so in the next part of the
talk
i'm going to go through uh the
strategies and infrastructures that
we've developed over the years for using
and building in neuroscience ontologies
and how they are being applied now
across three projects the first is the
brain initiative cell census network
these are the
groups of neuroscientists who are trying
to use cutting-edge techniques to
gain a handle on how many cell types are
there
and i'm going to talk about how we're
representing neuron phenotypes
using ontologies as a way to translate
between experimental science and general
knowledge
i'm going to talk about the stimulating
peripheral activity to relieve
conditions or spark project
this is a large project that's trying to
map the autonomic nervous system
and we're using and extending anatomical
ontologies
uh across data models and circuitry
diagrams to build a cohesive platform in
a large knowledge base
and if i have time i'll get into the
reprint project which is
reproducible neuroimaging and their
concept of federated data elements
i understand that if i don't get to
reaper name david kennedy who leads that
project is coming
soon so he will be able to pick up where
i left
off so let's start with the neuron
phenotype ontology or as i like to say
how to have fair disagreements this is
really the work of tom gillespie was a
graduate student in my lab
and shawn hill our colleague at the blue
brain project
and uh it was designed again to have a
to deal with this fact that since we
don't know how many cell types there are
in the nervous system
how do we gain some traction on
representing and translating amongst the
different classification schemes that
have been generated
so if you look at neuron classification
schemes this is where somebody goes into
a brain region and
based on some set of properties says
well i think that there's
five major cell classes the problem of
gabaergic
interneurons in the cortex which is just
one region of the brain
has literally generated in the last few
years
dozens and dozens of different
classification schemes that have been
proposed
for them they usually measure a set of
process of
properties a lot of experimental data
they distill that down
into some sort of proposal which is
usually presented as a table
and of course everybody has its own
table
we know that some of these are due to
experimental
artifacts or the fact that group a
measured these sets of phenotypes and
group b measured these sets of
phenotypes
but we'd like to think that inside of
all this data it is trying to
come to the conclusion that there are in
fact discrete cell types that transcend
any one of these techniques right some
sort of universal knowledge about this
but again the way that this data is
typically published and this is meant to
overwhelm and confuse
is that you distill down all this
different experimental data that you see
you get this table and then you're
supposed to be able to compare across
these tables
i can't think of anything more unfair
than the way that we turn
currently communicate about cell types
in the nervous system
so the neuron phenotype ontology was
designed
uh as a common data model for expressing
neuronal types as extension collect
extensible collections of phenotypes
essentially taking those tables
and turning it into something that is
interoperable according to the fair data
principles
and the way that we had to do this was
sort of abandon uh
a realist perspective on the fact that
there is a neuron and there's only one
type of neuron we're trying to get to
those types that they're talking about
here
and just recognize that a lot of times
all we have are classes of neurons that
are a bunch of phenotypic properties
so we basically decided to embrace the
reality
of the way neuroscience is done instead
of
the way that we were taught to develop
ontologies which means i have to
tie very closely to some universal
realistic perspective of what's there
so neurons themselves are modeled as
bags of phenotypes
these phenotypes come from major
ontologies so they have identifiers
they're fair they're species there's
anatomical
molecular morphological physiological
but we define
two different types something that we
call common usage type
which is typically the thing that's
covered in an ontology these are things
that have been studied
by hundreds of labs over the years they
are recognized across multiple species
it doesn't really matter whether you use
a particular technique there are
multiple techniques that allow you to
develop them so they've really passed
into
common knowledge but we distinguish that
with what we call these evidence-based
models or evidence-based types and these
are ones that again
represent what you saw in the previous
slides these are groups of people
usually sets of experiments or projects
that have employed a set of set
techniques they've gone ahead and
created a classification scheme and they
want to
communicate that and
the evidence-based type again differs in
several fundamental ways from the common
usage type the common usage type is
generally species and
species independent that is you will
find them across multiple species a
pyramidal cell is the pyramidal cell's
pyramidal cell
and you see it across multiple species
they typically again come from a
specified
source which is a laboratory a project
so you can trace the provenance back
to an individual group whereas you can
for some of these common uterus types
say the first person who described it
but they generally didn't describe it in
totality right this represents the
general work of the community to
understand what this common neutral type
is it always comes from a specific
species and strain because that's what
that group is studied so it's tied very
closely
to an individual species
the class definitions are driven by data
they've actually been
collecting data on this and what we've
done is we've taken
a set of python scripts and that allow
you to take the phenotypes that have
been collected by that laboratory that
would be in that table
and turn that into a more formal
representation
using owl semantics the web ontology
language
that actually relates those phenotypes
to individual ontologies through their
identifiers
so it says you can say whatever you want
about this we will give you something
that lets you
uh convert your uh names
into owl statements so this is all done
automatically through python
and then we can generate automatically a
consistent naming scheme
for these neurons based on these
phenotypic properties
which right now looks like this just
long string almost like a gene sequence
of all of the different phenotypical
characters that go into defining this
neuron class
so you see species anatomy morphology
electrophysiology
this is all done automatically again
nobody needs to do anything
so this differs from a lot of the ways
that
common naming schemes are put in where
you get agreement from
a group of experts that say this is how
you're going to name it and then you
manually go
and follow that scheme these are all
done automatically and handled through
the ontology
so these evidence-based types tie very
closely
to what it is that the experimentalists
reported
and that means that if you actually look
at these names in their reality
they can be quite messy so these are all
the
same entities that are color coded
according to different
schemes josh huang henry markrum allen
brain
and s1 is the primary somatosensory
cortex
it's called neocortex and wong it's
primary visual cortex here that comes
from a specific
atlas in the allen this one is our
common usage type which says well
generally these cells are found in
neocortex layer two and three
and you can see that all of them seem to
have something to do with the
neurotransmitter gaba but this one
has gaba receptors this one has gaba
channels this one has the actual
neurotransmitter gaba
and so on and so forth so when you look
at the terminology that happens
amongst the different labs you can see
that there's a lot of variation
and to relate this requires a lot of
human knowledge
and that's really what the neuron
phenotype does that's the benefit
of turning this into that formal
representation it essentially takes
all of those different brain regions for
examples whether they're specific
instances of a parsilation scheme
or whether they're generic concepts like
neocortex it relates those together
it takes all the different ways you
could represent a molecular species to
say that this is for example a
somatostatin neuron
and it says if you have any of these and
you have any of these
then you're considered a cortical
somatostatin neuron so it basically
allows you to express that complexity
but then it does reasoning on top of
that to collapse it down to its
universals
so if you want to say find all
somatostatin containing cortical neurons
it can do that it can pull all these
things out regardless of the local
terminology
and it does this through these
ontological structures
so the same practice that we used
for relating experimental types
and common usage types in neurons is
also something that we did to handle
all those different parcellation schemes
we basically introduced two different
types of anatomical structure
one is equivalent it's a common usage
brain region it's a brain region that we
all talk about
it is in anatomy textbooks but
essentially it's
stateless and it's stateless and species
independent so you can find anterior
cingulate in a whole bunch of species
stateless i mean that it it corresponds
to a specific region of brain if you're
taught neuroanatomy
it'll tell you where it is but the
boundaries of it are only generally
defined in specific experimental
techniques so when we say
anterior cingulate and you say what do
you mean by anterior cingulate we can
say well
we can't tell you without additional
data all we know is it's roughly here
but we contrast that to the parcellation
schemes
which again are like these experimental
base types these are tied to specific
species
and representations and they generally
have atlases and borders that are
associated with them so the provenance
of that usage is very clear
if i say neocortex you only have a
general sense of what i mean
if i say m1 according to x then you know
exactly what i mean
so we've kind of again
created the sort of dual branches one
more conceptual and general
and universal and one that's very much
specifically tied to these specific
artifacts
so this has been a very useful exercise
it's still in its early stages
but we've already been being able to
show that it does help translate for
example between phenotypes coming from
the hbp the human brain project and
bluebrain project in europe
and those that are coming from the brain
initiative and it lets you essentially
express all those complex phenotypes in
a common language which lets you compare
them
and again we make no statements about
whether these are the same neurons or
not we merely say that they
share or they don't share features and
we leave it up to the experimentalists
to argue about that
but at least again they can look at all
the data as you remember in the
beginning
that would let them try to answer this
question
instead of having to navigate all that
themselves
so i'll skip that one there so the next
one
that i'm going to talk about is
anatomical vocabulary services in the
spark project and this again is
tom gillespie and my colleague bernard
de bono and monique serlis ziegler who's
a postdoc in my lab
and the spark project just to give you
some introduction to it
is all about being able to use neural
modulation
that is sticking electrodes and various
devices into peripheral nerves to be
able to relieve a variety of conditions
they've been sticking electrodes in and
claiming all kinds of effects if you
stimulate the vagus
but it was realized again that we
actually knew
relatively little about the autonomic
nervous system we've had general maps
for 100 years but we don't really know
the detailed trajectories that these
different nerves take
so the idea of spark is that it is
supposed to put
neuromodulation therapy or bioelectronic
medicine as we call it
on a much firmer experimental
basis by developing a huge knowledge
base
set of data and connectivity maps
that are directly targeted to the
autonomic nervous system
so this is being done through something
called the spark consortium there are
well over 60 labs 500
individuals or so that are participating
and they're basically creating maps of
connectivity and physiology
across 15 different organs and systems
all of this data is being made available
to something called the spark data and
resource
center of which we are apart and
you can go to the spark portal and
actually start to find this data
and see what it is that has been done i
could spend an entire lecture on this
but i'm going to go through it
relatively quickly and focus
more on the back end of how we're using
anatomical ontologies to help enable
all of the things that spark needs to do
so one of the big things that spark is
producing
are these connectivity maps it has an
interactive interface which shows
the individual nerves that connect
different parts of the organs
these these things are all connected to
data sets they're mapped to 3d scaffold
and also simulation platforms
underlying these lines is actually a
very sophisticated model which plots not
only that structure a connects to
structure b but also the trajectory it
takes so that you know what nerve bundle
it goes through what anatomical
structures it goes through
so that if you are placing electrodes
you would get a sense of
what the local tissue environment is
that information is not available
through this interface but it is being
made available through a knowledge base
of ans
circuitry that is using a very
sophisticated model you can see that
down here how precise the different uh
pathways are and which
which structures they traverse and this
we're creating a semantic knowledge base
that contains this information
and i'd love to talk to you about this
but we're not yet up to our first
release
so i'm not really going to talk about
this in too much detail
but this is a place where we're really
using the full reasoning power of
ontologies and full representation to
create a very sophisticated
knowledge base instead
i'm going to talk about the fact that
because spark is producing so many
different things it's producing
flat maps that's producing 3d scaffolds
it's producing
data sets that having consistent
anatomical annotation
across these things and across the 500
people who are involved in spark
is really quite critical for it to be
successful right you want people to be
able to pass easily from one
representation to the next and you want
them to be able
to understand exactly what it is that
they're looking at
when they see these structures so
we are putting spark from the get-go on
a firm ontological
backbone we're using a community
ontology called uberon supplemented by
the foundational model of anatomy for
human terms as our annotation framework
but as i mentioned before those
ontologies tend to be fairly coarse
and they don't get down to the level of
detail that one needs if you're
producing this type of detailed
anatomical data
and these and these detailed route maps
so one of the challenges that we've had
is how we go about allowing this fair
annotation to happen without being
constrained by what's available through
these community ontologies
so one of the things that we did was
we've incorporated these ontologies into
the main segmentation tools and
annotation tools that are being used
this is actually a tool that's produced
by micro brightfield or
former micro brightfield mbf bioscience
which lets people contour
and do these detailed delineations of
their data sets
these are all lists of anatomical terms
here's metadata about the species that
is being used
but if you actually look behind the
scenes that's actually translating this
information
into identifiers and so that mapping is
happening
automatically when the researchers are
annotating they don't need to do
anything
afterwards problem is of course is then
they get d
deep in here as i mentioned they may
encounter a structure
that isn't in the ontology so what do we
do in that case
well the nif project cycrunch you can
see
again both of these terms in here
actually maintains an infrastructure
that allows people
to on the fly add terms to a database
called interlex
receive an identifier and then later on
do the knowledge engineering to relate
that to other terms
or even contribute them back to
different ontologies
so essentially when people are
annotating if there's a new term it gets
added
to interlex it then gets its identifier
they're free to annotate with it and as
i'll show you we have a review process
later to sort of see
how well that goes um the full ontology
is served through something called
scigraph which is a neo4 based
neo4j based system you can either
access interlex or scigraph through
services if you want to incorporate this
into again an
annotation workflow like you saw with
the mbf tool
so just to look at interlex a little bit
more it's essentially an online lexicon
or dictionary of biomedical terms it
largely draws those terms from
community ontologies that exist already
maintaining the
identifiers and some of the relations it
doesn't have all of them but it has some
of them
but its main power is that users can add
link and modify
metadata within interlex so they can add
their own terms
they can change definitions they can do
all of that basically they can do with
the ontology is what they want to do
and all of this is captured in um
versioning number
and provenance so that essentially it
becomes a sort of a living
laboratory of what people want to do
with these concept
it's really designed to provide the
necessary coverage for this type of deep
annotation of experimental data without
at the same time we contribute to
community ontologies but we don't have
to wait to submit those terms wait for
it to be approved and so on and so forth
neither if you're doing experimental
data even though a lot of ontologies
have term request pipelines
you may have to use ontology's four or
five different ontologies when you're
annotating
a single data set and you don't want to
have to go to four to five different
uh term requests so it's
a very sort of powerful system but it's
again designed to serve as the interface
between the experimentalists and these
community ontologies
so just to look in a little more detail
each term is assigned
a a uniform resource identifier so a
full uri
it's mapped to other terms if they exist
it's tagged with who
it is contributed it can be related to
different terms if you
wish those can come in through bulk
upload or you can add them yourselves
there's a commenting thread on each one
of them that can be used for discussion
and it has some curatorial tools so if
for example like spark there's an
approval process for something to be
used
or approved for the spark vocabularies
there are a set of
curation tools that people can use to
say yes this has been approved or no it
hasn't again
everything gets in not necessarily
everything gets approved
so how does that approval process work
in spark we actually do maintain
something called the spark anatomical
working group
these are a set of independent experts
anatomical experts who serve
as consultants to spark currently
they're gary ma
and jerry jackie bresnahan plus a
network of experts
every new term that's submitted to spark
gets reviewed by sog
it's not a matter of them rejecting or
accepting them
it is a quality control review however
so for example
we had one term that was used to
annotate data called the thoracic anza
it was brought to the sog and they said
we've never heard of this term and we
have no idea what they mean
we went back to the investigator and
they said oops that's actually a mistake
that's not what it should have said
so it was able to actually correct an
error which is a very important
there are other areas where they suggest
terms where one said
they wanted to call it empty area and we
said does this refer to extracellular
space the investigator said no no this
is a fixation artifact so we said
well actually this might be a better
term and they were willing to use it
even if they had used it as a synonym
right we would have had that mapping
but essentially again this is not that
sort of consensus-driven process this is
just a review
for clarity sometimes we get terms and
the
the experts say you know what that
really should be an uber on
uh and we recommend that we we go then
go through and we submit it to uber on
so that we build up their representation
of the peripheral nervous system
so essentially what we've done in spark
is we've implemented the infrastructure
and a workflow in a process
for both being formal about what it is
that we use in our annotations
but given the flexibility to build
content area
that is not yet in community ontologies
and also
those very detailed uh structures that
often
are necessary for annotating
experimental data that really don't
belong in community ontologies for
example we get a lot of junctions
between two structures
and it goes through again this process
of approval everything gets in
to interlects so it's available for use
but only some things get into the spark
ontologies which get built into nif
some of them go to uber on and so on and
so forth so this is how we balance the
need for formalism
with the flexibility that we need for
experimental neuroscience and it looks
like i have a few minutes
to go through reapernym so i will do
that and again i think you'll
hear a little bit more about this from
david kennedy so
this is a reaprenim which is the center
for reproducible neuroimaging
computation
my colleagues david kennedy jeff grata
satra dave and
yarick are all listed below and they all
know a lot more about this than i do
i do i am involved but not as heavily as
these gentlemen and essentially as
you'll hear about
reprint m is again really
geared towards data and it's geared
towards
making the process of acquiring and
analyzing
neuroimaging data much more reproducible
so they cover the main areas study
design
data collection data processing
statistical analysis and publications
they provide details on how you can do
this in a much
firmer computational footing and a much
fairer way than we typically do it right
now
but one of the things that's sort of
integral to
reapernym is this idea of annotation
right that
annotation of metadata all experimental
details
do need to be annotated and the more
they are done so in a fair way
the more that metadata is available for
downstream analysis
and comparison so annotation is very
very critical to this entire process
they are and what are they annotating to
well there is a
core vocabulary i think jack was
involved in this called the
knight em neuro imaging data model i
should say a data model
and that has data set descriptors it
deals with experiments workflows results
it also has a vocabulary that can be
used
to describe these things and annotate
these things
it's based on something called prov
which is a w3c standard for
looking at provenance you can see what
that looks like right over here
and it's a very sophisticated and uh
fairly complex model
that serves as one of the back ends for
the reprinting
strategy so i'm not going to go too much
into what it is that reapernym does in
terms of their technology stack
but one thing is clear right that there
needs to be a robust annotation
framework
this crosses everything all right that
one does this is the annotation
and you can see here that they also are
using the interlex
system in order to balance this need for
formalism
with the need to be able to add things
as needed in these very complex and
often
customized workflows so it's the same
infrastructure that we're using for
spark
one of the outcomes of all of this
annotation is that they are building
a data lake which is a public repository
that will have all of this annotated
data in it they also allow researchers
to develop their own local data stores
but just as with the other contexts that
we've seen
narrow imaging is characterized by a lot
of different packages there's a lot of
software that's out there there's a lot
of customized routines so fsl
and ants and free surfer and all of
these different things are built into
different workflows so these are all
being mapped
knight em and one of the things
that one of the places where ontologies
are really coming into play
is in essentially annotating the data
elements that are produced by these
different packages
so that's what i'm going to focus on for
the last part of this talk
so if you look at common data elements
there was a big push at nih to create
common data elements for different types
of things
there are data elements that actually
come out of these packages so there's a
tool called
free surfer and it measures the caudate
nucleus the left caudate nucleus volume
so it basically
if you run that package you will get a
chunk of tissue that corresponds to
the left caudate nucleus according to
free surfer
uh you'll get the same thing if you use
a package called amps
one of the things that jeff grata and
dave keeter have done is they basically
are
taking these common data elements and
they're turning them into
what are called community data elements
so they're taking the different pieces
of these data elements and mapping them
to
ontological concepts that are relevant
so for example the caudate nucleus from
uber on
the left side which is laterality the
units
from the unit ontology so they're
creating these sort of semantic data
elements that are coming from this
so that means that though that the ants
and free surfer
are both now expressed in the same
common language
one that is fair and therefore
computable and formalizable
so that's one step the second step which
i think is rather neat is that they've
introduced the concept of something
called a federated data element
so you can take these community data
elements that have been mapped to these
formal concepts
and now say that there does exist
something called left caudate nucleus
volume
and that can be expressed in free surfer
that can also be expressed in
ants again we know that there are
differences in the way that these things
are defined and we know that there's
differences in the way
um and probably disagreements in the way
that are
and also measured right so these two
things may not be equivalent
whoops i'm getting to the end here but
at least you have enough you have the
chance of understanding that the left
caudate nucleus has been measured and
the provenance of that is clear
through these deep semantics so i hope
you can see
that um this is a use of ontology again
not to drive consensus but just
to express and reveal what is in the
latent
tools in a way that is interoperable
so actually this is good timing
where are we now compared to 2008 when
all
young and fresh we decided that we would
be able to go out and create ontologies
for neuroscience
well i think that there are several
things that are in our favor now
neuroscience is going i would say slowly
towards fair
but fair is tough so that doesn't
surprise me
but groups that never before cared about
data standards or vocabularies are now
starting to talk
about them those who are developing the
brain archives for example like satrajin
gauche are using ontology identifiers
in their data models so that again the
problems that nif had in the beginning
will not be solved but they will be less
okay so
i think this is finally permeating the
mindset of a lot of people doing
neuroscience
but the process that we've built the
models the infrastructure
and for working and building fair
vocabularies
we really implemented a process that we
believe is suitable for experimental
neuroscience
it lets the experimentalists work where
they are provides these translation
services
and formalizes knowledge about the
the universals that we share in
neuroscience and doesn't worry so much
about these other leave notes because
those are at the cutting edge and those
are tied to specific data and data sets
that we hope
will also be fair so that we can start
to examine these concepts and say do
they have any validity or not we're not
telling them
yes or no so we don't you notice in this
at any point insist on consensus at no
point do we have everybody in the room
agreeing on anything rather we align
this common knowledge
ourselves with more experimental
concepts to promote search and
interoperability
so the good news is is i think we are
really getting some tractions
but also we still believe very strongly
in these community ontologies they're
very valuable and so all of our efforts
are enriching these with neuroscience
content and terms
although using a bottom-up approach
instead of top-down
and i think that's it so thank you very
much for your attention
marianne thank you so much that was uh
uh it's always
interesting whenever i have students
come to me and they i say well what do
you want to do when you you know in
neuroscience and say oh i want to
understand the brain
right i think just if you just kind of
watch a talk by marianne martone it'll
give you a a an understanding of the
hill you're going to be climbing
it is a complex beast i you know you in
your talk which was fantastic by the way
and you covered so much ground i think
everybody
appreciates that you really kind of made
the linkage between
this kind of just natural linkage
between brain science with all of its
different
terms and it's all these different
levels of granularity and
ontological sciences um and how that
relates to
how you can promote fairness i'm kind of
curious what you view
as the connection to what we now think
of as data science we must
once called it kind of informatics but
now it's really data science
where's that connection the
computational element of things
i have my marvelous quote somewhere let
me see if i can find it i'll just put
this up because this is one of my
favorites
i didn't know if i would have time to
get to it so
you do see these two strains right which
says
well i've got all this data all i need
to do is put this data together
and i'm going to find new things and i
really don't need
these concepts right these concepts
aren't really necessary because i'm
going to be able to look for data
signatures
and everything i need is in the data and
i
i saw this wonderful blog a few years
ago and i i took the concepts from it
where they
they contrasted the semantic idealist
with the chaotic nihilist right
and so you know the idea and they said
these are big data's odd couples right
these
she's abandoned any hope of properly
tagging the world and relies on machines
to find the most relevant or appropriate
information
her kind or the machine learning data
scientists are convinced that given
enough data in the right algorithm the
best results will
bubble to the top uh and you know you
you contrast that with sort of the
ontological world as the semantic
idealists who fetishize taxonomies we
have to tag and organize it all
and i think we all recognize that
there's an interplay between these two
so um you know i always say render under
semantics what goes to semantics and
render onto data what goes to data and i
think one of the problems that the
when i was first interacting with the
ontology community is their idea of data
was
very different than mine their idea of
data was this distilled knowledge that
was inside of papers
and i said no no no what we're talking
about is data is this right
these are the numbers and these are the
measurements and ideally you want these
two
to agree and that's why i emphasize now
assertions
so when i take something like this and i
assert that it is something
that we would consider a universal right
something that we understand
you would ideally like to be able to say
that i have asserted
that this thing is an x so i've asserted
that this is a mitochondria in a
in a you know a gene network but you
would also like the gene network
to have some validity that this is a
mitochondria right that it basically
says oh look right i've localized this
to mitochondria and this one has dna
sequences that are
have been in the past associated with
with mitochondria
so i find that this sort of back and
forth you're still going to have to take
all this
right and you're still going to have to
conceptualize it because that's how
human beings communicate with each other
that's how we understand
but you really want them to work in
tandem and you don't want to force
one structure into the other let data
handle what data handles
let these assertions handle what they
what they
handle they handle making it easy to
search because even though everybody
wants the algorithm that's going to go
across the web and find data signatures
right now
that's extremely difficult to do so if
you are going to search you're going to
put in a term right you're going to say
this is what i'm trying to find
but if we get hung up that those terms
are accurate
and all-encompassing we're never going
to get anywhere right to me
these two things come together so i
assert that those
yellow dots are about something that i
know
and in the future you would like to make
sure that any time you see that pattern
of yellow dots
that it is tied with that assertion so
as somebody said once i think was
jeffrey builder who's from crossref
he said uh if i assert
that i'm marianne martone that's one
thing and most of you will believe me
and i say that i work at ucsd you'll say
okay
that sounds reasonable if you then go to
a database at ucsd
and they say oh yes here's marianne
martin identified by her orchid and she
does in fact work here
then that is a much stronger right bit
of evidence than just say so so i
believe that these assertions again
provide us a way of communicating about
meaning
they help in search but ultimately
you want them all to be able to agree
with each other so that's why i really
emphasize that
if i go to five different databases with
five different bunds of yellow dots
and they're all in different places and
mitochondria is scattered throughout it
means i probably don't understand what a
mitochondria is
and i certainly can't recognize it in
data there's no consistency there
let's let's contrast that right where i
say
oh i go to five different databases they
all have annotations on
mitochondria and when i combine those
data together they're all pretty close
you know we're going to get 100 but
they're pretty close that suggests that
the concept of mitochondria has some
validity
in a bunch of different experimental
contexts and that therefore it's a good
thing for us to you know build our
theories on top of it
so i think that you know really what i'm
i'm advocating
is to use them where they're appropriate
but not to worry again about saying oh
this is exactly in the right place of
the hierarchy it's just meant to be
uh a way of us to formalize our shared
understanding of what all this data
means
i don't know if that answered your
question but i i think so
i love this slide it's very good because
it's it actually your comment leads me
into another question of
you know these databases and uh these
various things like the interlex tool
for example seems like a very powerful
framework
um to what degree does it interact with
things like
omop or ohdsi that are
databases uh in the clinical space
yes so currently we sort of sit in the
basic science
spaces and um we we do not interact with
them
um but there's no reason why it could
not right there's no reason why
the approach it it can ingest anything
and anyone can
ingest what we have because we just need
to make the linkage you just need to
make the linkage yeah okay
uh one final thing and i always kind of
use this as a joke when i'm giving a
presentation on it is when i discuss the
fair principles
i say that uh fair uh it's unappreciated
but fair has a silent
e on the end and that e stands for
education
or educational in that uh it can be
findable accessible interoperable
reusable and educational
do you find that there is um a role for
fairness in education both kind of
uh on the giving end and on the
receiving end if you know what i mean
yes so actually i gave uh we had a
summer of data program through uc
through dknet
where uh we take in student interns and
instead of doing data science which is
what they expect we do data fundamentals
like data management
fair data and all the things that are
necessary so
one of the sayings that i have is you
know you have to prepare to
share and you have to prepare to share
fair because it requires effort on your
part and
that fairness can be sharing just with
or that sharing can be just with your
colleagues or your pi
or it can be with the world in general
but i was very surprised
in all the lectures the one that the
students liked the most was the fair
lecture i gave
because i think it started them to sort
of think about again
data as more of a primary product of
their research
and not the thing that you munge and
discard
and then move on to the next and so i
think it puts
data management into a context that says
well what am i supposed to do in terms
of managing my data it's like well
you know you need to make it
understandable you need to make it
understandable to human
but here's an example and i use a lot of
specific examples of
this is what's in your lab notebook this
is a shorthand are you going to know
what that shorthand means
actually the shorthand is a mouse that
is from
a catalog and you can use a research
resource identifier
to put that in and then you can use
whatever shorthand you want
so i think in terms of understanding
what it is that you're trying to achieve
when you're managing your data it's very
powerful at the same time
just like with ontologies i believe in
what i call the fair handshake
right you don't have to do everything
you have to understand that if you
really want to achieve fairness you're
going to likely hand it over
to a data repository or a data archive
that's going to do some of the other
work for you so you don't have to do
everything your job is to get it
here i don't know of any student
who doesn't appreciate when i show them
you know examples of data with rich
metadata and data without rich metadata
saying which one would you rather
try to grapple with right they all go to
the one with rich metadata they're like
well this one's much better
right this one is much better and so i
think it both promotes their reuse
because a lot of the ones that have no
metadata
they can't find it they can't open it
they don't know who did what
they see that that data is fundamentally
unusable whereas over here
where and students are i think are
really reliant on
using other data in many cases because
they're doing short lab rotations they
have to do research projects they don't
always
get to generate all their own so i i do
think it goes both ways and it's a
powerful framework
for understanding what we're trying to
achieve even though there's many ways to
do it
when we're managing our data and then
making it available
marianne martzone thank you so very much
for sharing uh this fantastic
tour of informatics of ontology design
for for brain science and
just trying to get it organized uh that
is a hero's amount of work i have to say
um thank you everybody who joined us um
everyone have a
great weekend we will see you all next
week in the meantime uh
here on the east coast uh we're digging
out from a snowstorm and uh for those of
you who are also digging out
uh good luck uh enjoy your weekend we'll
see you soon it's uh it's
80 degrees here just kidding
in southern california yes exactly all
right
thank you everyone